[Music]
oh
guys that's beautiful
uh where did we get to
what did we do oh we
we unlocked the front door didn't we
we unlocked this one
sweet
i'm gonna turn this up oh gosh that
might be a bad idea
this is very atmospheric it's actually
giving me pt vibes
[Music]
yes major pt vibes
i don't want i don't want i don't want i
don't want i don't want i don't want i
don't want
can i just walk past and just ignore it
like it didn't happen can i close the
door
oh right yeah both ways that makes sense
hello
there's something in there it's watching
me
or in there oh my goodness
okay
hello oh god it's empty
a memento of my time with ethan but this
music box no longer plays
why is this here
wait hold up i don't want to do anything
yet yeah yeah
don't worry
i feel like something bad's gonna happen
as soon as i do that
okay screw it we're doing it
what i can't use it here oh damn it i
don't have anything
do i no i do
huh what are we trying to play here
let's can we just play it
see what happens
[Music]
something is not right there
is this going to be something that's
highly obvious
or am i going to have to work this out
because
it doesn't seem obvious to me
is it to do with the scratches do you
think
the scratches need to line up possibly
possibly
i mean that one looks like it goes with
that one and that one looks like it goes
without
one maybe or maybe this one
goes next to that one so maybe if i do
this
yeah ah
but what about this one this one seems
like a little bit of an odd ball really
i think that one goes here and maybe
maybe like this
no that can't be right
[Music]
okay i know where that one is i know i
know i know
that's right
some spooky tweezers
oh hell no
i love how the music is so dramatic it's
like
tweezers okay
i guess i can use excuse me door you are
in my way that's not good door
i should have walked past you when i had
the bloody chance
fine whatever i'll turn around
oh good thank you door
sorry to stop because i heard a bang
i know i probably have to go back to the
mannequin but
i wondered if i could open that
wait what our happy family rosa's best
friend
in the whole wide world she really likes
this fairy tale
the most important thing in the world to
us a wedding
gift from grandma proof of ethan's
everlasting love for me
an old production and some half edited
film
three isn't there the most important
thing in the world to us
isn't there
so that's rose that's
the wedding wing the wedding wing
that is i don't even know what that is
it's a book
oh and that's the um
that's the music box why can't i do
anything here
alkaloids are mountainous plants right
we're leaving
we're going back to the mannequin
[ __ ] jesus what the hell
okay this house is going apart
i think she has something in her mouth
oh this is the rest of the film
what's the wiggle titty but oh my god
um
what what can't you tell me
okay i'm just gonna save because because
why the hell not right
that's weird noises
okay okay okay we seem to be okay
sure let's let's wait
oh right they're not in order okay
gotcha gotcha
enlarge
[Music]
sleeping baba um let's read this again
rose's best friend in the whole wide
world right so that's going to be the
monkeys right it's got to be the monkeys
um she really likes this fairy tale
the most important thing in the world to
us so
monkey book her
wedding ring and the jewelry box
monkey book her wedding ring jewelry box
monkey book her wedding ring
and a jewelry box
yep is that good to go
what
favorite thing in the world she loves
this story
ah most important thing it's gotta be
that
rosa's best friend in the whole wide
world a monkey she likes this fairy tale
a book the most important thing to us
her
a wedding gift from grandma oh wait
definitely derped up obviously ethan's
everlasting love has got to be the
wedding ring i for some reason
read it as like a wedding ring from
grandma
but no no it's not already ring from
[Music]
grandma
am i watching the ring now
okay whoa
whoa
okay so there is a
spooky ass freaking well
and the house wants me to go down these
do i still not have guns or anything
nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
that scared me
just dolls although this one's quite
cute
i like this one with this little hat on
his head i like him
why are there like so many female dolls
and then this is the lonely boy doll
the lonely boy clown oh no no no you're
here too with a pair of scissors
he's very helpful he's a very helpful
boy clown
sailor i don't know what he is
thanks for following santiago three nine
one seven
okay so i've got some scissors but what
do i need them for
oh right
here hello
okay nice
ah brilliant a phone
nope too good to be true
should we try again
i don't know why he's so anxious picking
up as if the second time would be any
different
come on ethan
of course
please ethan listen to me i didn't
want to keep it from you yeah i didn't
want to lose you again
i didn't want to destroy this family mia
what are you talking about
i love you both so much
i had to i had to do it what did you do
what
did she give us her weird fungus thing
and that's why ethan can just plop his
hand back on like it ain't nothing
okay i'm guessing you're locked
oh i'm back here
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
who was that is that the puppet maker
what the hell were they doing here
[Music]
i don't like it i don't like it
[Music]
okay this is keeping my edge because we
haven't
done anything really like for a long
time and something's gonna happen
and i'm just
scare
so have i done everything here oh
scissors
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh yes
hello i'm waiting for something to
happen
okay this is the last piece right
is that right
is that not right
i thought it was a flying bird maybe
it's this
i have to go and check something like
this
[ __ ]
no i don't want to go down here
oh god
[Music]
i can hear something swaying i don't
like it
this is horrific
of course it's a freaking baby
cradle stop please
ethan doesn't like it
uh
just small puppets i break a box okay
what could that kibby do
i don't even know
oh god
up here up here ethan just go
[Music]
get back to my safe room
oh god this is not my safe room
what happened oh my god what the hell
it won't be fine
can i save i don't feel safe
why are weird scary things happening in
a place with a typewriter
this doesn't feel right
okay let's follow the umbilical cord i
guess
follow the umbilical cord follow the
umbilical cord
what oh my god
what is it what is it
oh yeah i don't know
[ __ ] is it what the [ __ ] is it
come on
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
this way
i hopefully can't come here it's a giant
fetus
say you didn't follow me around i don't
know what what i'm supposed to be doing
in here
i got a nice close-up of that big baby
fetus
oh my god i hate when the game does this
it's just my computer i don't know why
does it i need to look into it
randomly pauses the game sometimes
does give good scare though oh i got the
breaker box key but don't i need a
baby figure to open that baby door
minimum yep ear drums destroyed i am
satisfied
it's just a lovely baby says photo score
what you're [ __ ] screaming about it's
just a baby
no but where is
the baby figure do i get it late oh
here it is i found it
i thought that was gonna allow me to use
the uh
nope okay great
oh i don't want to do this
it's giving me literal shivers
which way was it was it left or right
i'm really bad at directions
the freak she's right there
please go get inside
okay i'm safe what's this
brassic gibb coss
say for now probably not very long
i hate not being able to pick anything
up
it's like a constant reminder that i
don't have anything
nice dress
can ethan wear it
fine
hide oh god i don't like that that's an
option
can i hide from both ends i'm guessing i
can
yeah okay uh great great great
hiding under the bed always always fun
for some reason i decided to try and
hide in in here
oh i can close it i was just kneeling
down
because that's what i do in phasmaphobia
just turn into a little ball and hope
for the best in phasmophobia
right um let's do this
something bad is gonna happen now
good
i feel like hiding under the bed is a
really bad option i feel like
whenever anyone hides under the bed in a
horror film just things go
drastically wrong
baby steps
[Music]
um
now what
oh no i don't want to go back upstairs
why am i going back upstairs
i got a fuse oh crap yeah of course
because of the beers
not hiding under the bed not hiding on
the bed not turning under the bed i'm
hunting here i'm hiding in here i'm
hiding in here close the door
and crouch
oh my god
oh
[Applause]
don't open
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
how am i gonna get out of here
okay that sounds promising
oh we should leave now
where did it go oh my gosh
look what it did to the floor
this thing is vile where did it go is it
still around
oh my gosh did it just disappear i mean
fine by me fine by me
yep looks like it
i don't
hmm
should we just run
yum
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
help me
oh
enough to make me never want to have a
child
i did not expect that bloody
[Music]
ethan's vision has gone wacky
yeah i get it you're an evil doll shut
up
yeah yeah yeah stop trying to be like
harley quinn or something
that's weird
what's this little dolls
hair dresses
i don't quite know
[Music]
huh don't leave i can't let you
you're still alive
[Music]
[Music]
right
try and find me
oh crap no i don't like this game i
don't want to play this game are you in
here
why do i go to the door i know it
doesn't open i mean
there's
a possibility
are you upstairs are you in here
are you okay
[Music]
oh here you are
i found you
[ __ ] monster yeah
[Music]
though
[Music]
i like how the dolls kind of guide you
towards where she is
if you follow like the shaking heads
uh down here maybe and the noises
obviously
oh now i'm way off
[Music]
oh no i've lost it where is she
dolls
okay maybe i was wrong
sure just can't be in here though
oh my god stop jesus okay
okay okay oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
where is she
there she is
she was so close i was just about to get
here
okay
idiot what are you doing to my cute
friends
oh killing her kills them both
mia we'll make things right
what
we got another piece of road this place
very nice very nice was i supposed to
do something with it oh yes
oh yeah of course so that's who's behind
all this
i got no strings
so where are my guns that makes two
oh cool we got to keep her
uh wearing me guns can i pick up
anything else now that i'm here
probably not i'm just going gonna have a
little look upstairs though
hello it'd be really nice if i could
just pick up as many of these dolls as i
could and then sell them to um
what's his name again i can't remember
his name
the dude who sells
and collects the merchant
because it would be imagined
okay where are my guns i guess i'll get
them back
eventually
yeah duke thanks pixelate duke
well auravoir
how do i get my guns back
oh my god santiago's like you have your
guns
what did i get these back when should i
pick them up
okay game games to be like this though
uh
if i do this really quick it looks like
he's got octopus hands
like he's got so many flailing arms
that took a while
obviously loading
why not been here before i would have
thought i would have broken that
because i just have i been here before
[ __ ] jesus christ jesus christ jesus
christ jesus christ
[Applause]
there they are no
no where are you this isn't fair i just
got out of like a really stressful
environment i
don't need this right now
oh
no no
there are items which cannot be
discarded in the discarder return them
to your inventory
can i put this over here because i don't
need it right now
explosive rounds nice i'm gonna put the
fish i'm gonna put all my meat
in here right and then i can save them
and stuff like
we'll save them sell them for recipes
later
and then can i have this now
okay there's another shotgun so we're
happy with this
oh [ __ ] jesus
okay that's nice that's nice they're
pretty nice that'd be nice
that'd be nice nice nice
i thought i just moved stuff around so i
could fit that in
oh i can't
i just need to get rid of something you
know what screw it i'm gonna get rid of
these
can i
can i use them now i haven't actually
used them
how do i use these
grenade launchers right i don't have a
grenade launcher
anyway i'm going to use
oh [ __ ] no out the window eastern out
the freaking
[Applause]
window
[Applause]
oh no not that the chem fluid to egypt
uh
okay right let's just
discard these because i don't even know
how to use them and i can't bother to
learn
so and we'll pick up you
cheers very nice very nice
oh look thick very nice and mine
yeah we definitely need to buy more
storage shall we
uh
okay so that's everything in here
where are we oh scheiser sorry i did it
again
where have we ended up at
gotta make sure to get this treasure
oh and aren't we also looking for a key
from benny
guards no
where would that be then
which way did we come did we come from
this way
that way no that's that's not okay good
all right we're gonna come back
that way to get the
[Music]
keep my eyes open for a key
looks like someone's been digging here
i never know
keep my eyes open for rekey
got sun and moon ball
don't know what that's for
keeping my eyes open for a key
[Music]
jesus
wait these are the first actual zombies
you've seen in the whole resident evil
game
you don't care about headshots
ah let's make some stuff
nice
and he
come on ball good ball good ball good
ball
good
come on
he's a specific
yes yes we got the key
exciting november 10th
mistress donna is now mother miranda's
adopted daughter
oh so that's lady dimitresk
in all my years i've never been this
overjoyed
ever since childhood she's always feared
others
due to the scar across her face oh
no no no that's the puppet lady
come on get it together puppet lady
yeah after her parents death she locked
herself away and would only talk to
angie
the really creepy doll that has flesh
inside of her head
um the doll her father made her i am
further
thankful to mother miranda's infinite
compassion
misjust donna seems happy it might be my
imagination but i feel like her dole
angie is even more lively than before
she came to me in the garden today and
used angie to talk with me
we had a mighty fine conversation
something about receiving a gift of
power from mother
mistress donna gave me yellow flowers
and told me to plant them in the garden
i planted them in front of bliss
claudia's grave
i don't know if it was the scent of the
flowers but i felt lightheart
lightheaded then um no i felt
lightheaded
then like a dream i saw my departed wife
oh so these plants are like
hallucinogenic flowers
and that's how we were able to see mia
and the demented giant fetus child
i mentioned this to donna and she seemed
thrilled by it
she told me to go to the house tomorrow
and see her she said
i could see my family once more i'm not
sure what she meant by that but
she's so kind is she though
is she hmm
i wouldn't be so sure i mean you're not
alive now and i'm guessing that's
not because of the zombies
okay so we have the key and that's
that's great
that's what i was searching for
willow alone
oh don't we have the body to this
we have the body to this so now we can
where was the body out here
yes and now we can sell the completed
doll
and get some extra money
huh let me see that
tis a photo of a strange bird
sorry my legs are really like
uncomfortable today
um
we know what that is maybe that's a clue
for something well i mean definitely
it's a clue for something
anything based on the back nope but for
what
i do not know a photo of a bird as blue
as the sky
where was it taken i know
i'll go back there we'll go back there
we'll check it out
okay so now i need to go back over the
suspension bridge
uh which way was that right behind me
oh god
oh god oh hello
in the book
[Applause]
uh
glad i did that
there were no zombies when i was here
before this is not fair
i can hear them everywhere
we [ __ ] die
please
can i knife you instead just
yeah it's good
fighting for you
[Music]
[Music]
this one
what's up here
oh do it
[Music]
stop singing disney songs while i'm
playing away
a little skeleton wait
that was dead end then
ah duke sweet juke where is he
duke sweet duke i'm back
oh why are you holding the doll that's
really creepy duke
okay does this look familiar to you
procured some new items for you mr
winters
great i also have a lot of things to
give you
it's on as creepy ass doll it doesn't
move anymore
it's very good
we haven't found all of the things for
the necklace yet
okay so that's a good amount of stuff
ah miss angie just adorable
porcelain dolls are very popular you
know
really okay please let me know if you'd
like to strengthen your weapons
have a wonderful adventure eating
enjoy your creepy ass doll
uh okay so now
i'm gonna go back down here have i
opened all the doors here
yet people i don't think so no we
haven't opened these ones have we
but we're gonna go back down here pew
pew
pew um
and check out the location of that bird
zombies everywhere oh no wait i can't be
bothered with this
oh god
oh yes they opened up this
finally ah
that's what the broken slab is too okay
we can go back and get that treasure
at some point now blue bird blue bird
blue bird
what does it mean
am i supposed to shoot it oh i'm sorry
oh i feel so bad juicy game
this game we can get the increased
permanent
health yet
juicy game c game
juicy game i got the juicy game
is this blood new oh of course it is
because i can open up the door
should we see if anything else has
changed in here no
wait there is one of those
wooden things in here i can hear it
where is it
is it up here
i mean there's this
where is it i can hear it
have you said anything new on here
no thank god i looked at the chat
because i could have been there for ages
like where is
this i guess if i go up here
i can ah
thanks guys and gals and nobody repels
and all that
trying to get better at that i'm trying
not to say guys
i want to be more inclusive just one of
those things that you do without
realizing
so now i can open the door up here i can
obviously open this one as well
oh yeah obviously i can put my thing in
there i should probably do that put my
thing in the altar and i'll go back to
get the treasure
oh and we can go into the new house
so many things to do what should we do
first oh so exciting
um all right let's go back
put our baby legs in the
the altar
legs
you proud of me you should be
oh and we're going to
go and get the treasure
because we can
fingers crosses bloody
zombies won't respawn
we were just here and that would be
extremely annoying
where was it oh let me think
what the frick hey black
bambi
oh i'm so mean for some reason i thought
i'd be
really hard to kill oh yeah we need to
go and get our
health permanent upgrade
so many things i can't keep i can't keep
track
is it down here yes down here
oh my freaking what the hell it was not
expecting me
[Music]
sure why the [ __ ] no don't put it down
jesus christ
oh my god
oh no
this episode is crazy
uh
get at least he's not going to come up
here that's one good
i underestimated it
oh my god i think my whole flat block is
gonna be like what the frick is this
girl doing
how do i kill you
[Music]
this is bad this is the bad bad fight
this is bad
hello
[Music]
um
oh my god it'd be really good if i had
that um
permanently higher health right about
now wouldn't it
that would be extremely useful okay so
i've just made a pipe bomb
that will help
hey dude
can i not kill you or something like
what is it
can i actually not kill you
i must be able to kill you
oh [ __ ]
how how am i supposed to kill that what
the hell
i'm sorry
oh god
[Music]
[ __ ] how did i
do that
how did i do that
i i honestly thought for a second there
that um every time i went around the
corner its health was
replenishing i had no
idea what was going on
i have absolutely oh
no are you kidding me
i'm so done with all of you
so done
there's so many of them i got it
i got it let's go wait there was a green
herb did they oh
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
i'm going home back to duke
oh geez
what a day what's a day how do i get
back out of here again
this way i was up to the house
please don't more surprise this game i
am so
out of ammo and everything right about
now
this chalice better have been worth it
that's all i'm saying
oh my gosh duke where are you i'm back
and that was a a real tough fight and i
had no idea that was about to happen
ah yes yes yes yes
yes um okay so
wait i thought i had two juicy game
[Music]
didn't i just get another juicy game
i could have sworn i had to nope
or was the bird something else i thought
the bird was juicy game
and i already had one didn't i nope
oh securing goods is more important than
anything
anything my friend
yeah i only got one
splendid do you know it's worth
and life is love do let me know if you
find anything else of value
what did i pick up juicy game
and quality meat
meat fish oh
i guess i didn't have juicy game i just
had quality meat
i need two juicy game it's time to stop
it's time to stop okay no more
so i need a juicy bird a juicy bird
i probably should get
i wonder if i can buy chem fluid
ah yes yes
i see anything else
please come again
okay i am real
not okay on the ammo front now which
doesn't make me feel good
but if i go up here by the poultry
i think i think i think i think
that unlocked maybe i should have saved
the game
that locked um
[Music]
i could save up here
locked door will have opened so let's
save the game
typewriter yeah
i cannot believe how much
how much ammo that thing took
i know still logs
all right let's get down to this locked
house then
uh
wait i can go through these doors down
here now
[Music]
there's also um
some treasure here but i don't know if i
have what i need
to get it or is that in the locked house
i don't know let's just go towards it
yes it is okay
happy birthday 2709
27 what was that 17
17.
anything for me to pick up because that
would be very nice
i'm in need for a lot of things right
now
thank you very much
sound like things are still soaring
around me this
is cool little music maker music maker
man
a woman or
dead fluid person
musical instrument maker since 1830
so i guess this is to that seven
six three nine three four seven six
three
nine three four seven six three
seven
six three
nine three
four no
did we get it wrong seven six three
nine three four i'll never get forget
her fifth birthday all right
no i was wrong that was a red herring
that was ah
can fluid yes it's nice
27 09 17.
27.09
17.
what we got here
okay
nice
oh nearly missed you
apparently there's still something in
here to pick up
so i will scour every
inch of this place because i need to
because i need everything i cannot
afford to miss
anything cause i don't wanna miss
something
i don't know what i could have missed
though
it doesn't seem to be much in here that
i could miss
what have i missed
anything on the ceiling anything
under the bed
seriously what the hell of a miss
getting angry
oh i don't know
meh oh well
oh chat just told me apparently there's
a gem in here
i'm such a cheater
thanks blue summers there's a
gem from one of the guitars
aha
beautiful thank you
okay well that was a nice little detour
you wish to make a purchase i wish to
sell
um just this one
now to spend like kings
so if i buy like a small
amount of health will that mean that i
won't be able to afford this one so it's
how much is this
um only one fish five meat that's a lot
of meat
i've only got four on hand
um
great oh the oh it's this one one one
so i need four poultry i've got seven
three me i've got four okay so i've got
everything
but then uh the health uh
health slightly is three fish
and two poultry
two poultry oh it's like
fish and poultry so i could buy the
small one now and i still
technically have enough to get the
greatly increases permanently
as well yeah poultry
four yeah no four
that one three
two two poultry three fish but we don't
care about fish
for this one all i care about is health
um i just want to make sure i don't do a
dum-dum here
i mean speed would be nice as well
though
oh apparently you can give him the meat
and he'll hold on to it that would be
really good actually
so maybe i can do that now yep
yep we've gathered all the ingredients
now
[Applause]
[Music]
finished i'd love for you to enjoy as
well
yay i got a tattoo too at that point
i don't know what the hell was wrong
with me but i was reading that as
it needed to juicy game and i was like
oh i need another two skin
i got it sweet my health is increasing i
wouldn't mind having that again
wait did we just eat with a duke that's
quite cute we just had a little dinner
with a duke
do we have anything for movement speed
then
oh we don't have enough for that
yeah i want the movement speed
but we don't have much there
okay i'm feeling pretty good i'm feeling
pretty good
i still need quite a lot of stuff but
overall we're getting there it's not so
bad
we'll just have to scrimp and search for
for
things to make bullets but i think i
think we're good i think we good
anyway that is the perfect place to end
it
and next episode we will be on to
a new boss um and trying to get the
third
section of rose's little wee baby body
i will see you guys next week at
the same time 8 30 pm bst